[Musique]
le problème ce n'est pas vous c'est nous
le problème ça n'est pas celles et ceux
qui naissent vivent dans la pauvreté
c'est ce qu'ils ne veulent plus les voir
et regarder ou s'habitue et nous devons
collectivement dans cette mobilisation
accepté l'idée aussi d'une conversion du
regard bonjour à tous changer le regard
de la société changer notre regard sur
la pauvreté c'était le message du
président de la république cette semaine
bienvenue pour la nouvelle saison de
dimanche en politique votre émission de
débat en franche comté ce matin vous
l'avez compris nous mettons sur la table
un enjeu de société comment endiguer la
précarité emmanuel macron on vient de le
voir à présenter lui-même ce jeudi et le
plan de du gouvernement contre la
pauvreté alors ce plan est il à la
hauteur des enjeux
comment endiguer la pauvreté faut-il
revoir la répartition des aides sociales
notre société stigmatise tels les plus
démunis on va en débattre avec nos
invités je voulais prenons tout de suite
d'abord pascal curie vous êtes délégué
municipal dès lé conseiller municipal
délégué à besançon membres de la
république en marche vous êtes également
président de grand habitat grand
besançon habitat qui gère plus de 5000
logements sociaux sur l'agglomération
également sur ce plateau antoine
aumônier délégué du secours catholique
pour la franche comté et puis à vos
côtés claire arnaud un militante de la
france insoumise membres du collectif je
suis assise collective créée suite à la
publication d'un arrêté municipal à
besançon arrêté qui visait les mendiants
c'était cet été bonjour à tous à tous
les trois merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
alors nouvelle saison dimanche en
politique mais on garde nos bonnes
habitudes vous pouvez interpeller nos
invités réagir à l'émission avec le mode
yes qui s'affiche dit mme paul fc comme
dimanche en dimanche en politique
franche comté je me ferais
relais de vos questions tout au long de
l'émission alors madame messieurs on
vient d'entendre le président de la
république est ce notre société le
problème pascal curie quand on parle de
pauvreté
non je pense pas c'est pas la société
notre société qui est le problème il
faut s'attaquer à la pauvreté
il ya eu un plan très important que le
président entend qu a décliné cette
semaine je crois que c'est un engagement
fort contrairement à ce que l'on a pu
dire je pense que le président c'est pas
aujourd'hui qui s'intéressent à la
pauvreté
on en a parlé il en a parlé donc en 2010
cette fin 2017 y avait pas très
longtemps qu'il est élu et il ya eu un
échange avec les associations le monde
associatif pour voir exactement quelles
étaient les besoins c'est d'ailleurs un
des responsables d'associations qu'ils
s'adressent dans l'extrait combien de
voir tout à fait et donc en partenariat
avec ces associations il ya eu des des
choses des éléments discutés et à partir
de là le plan était donc publié cette
semaine alors claire arnoux avant l'été
une autre phrase du président de la
république avait créé la polémique c'est
la fameuse phrase sur le pognon dingue
on met un pognon de dengue en france
dans les minima sociaux et les gens sont
quand même pauvre est ce que finalement
c'est pas en aveu d'échec de toutes les
politiques sociales menées par les
différents gouvernements successifs ont
déjà ce qu'on peut dire c'est que là
pour le coup emmanuel macron ne met pas
un pognon dengue dans son implant
pauvreté puisque et ses 8 milliards mais
après il faut savoir à quoi ça
correspond c8000 ya en fait dans les 8
milliards il ya quatre milliards qui
sont en fait de la réorientation ou
salesse que 4 milliards mais admettons
sur 8 milliards si on divise par le
nombre de pauvres en france à 8 8
millions ça fait 62 centimes par jour et
par personne
en considérant 8 milliards et pas quatre
comme je viens de vous dire donc déjà là
on peut pas dire qu'il ya un pognon
dengue qui soit versé sur ce plan là
donc j'ai ressassé le premier point
après moi quand je l'entends dire il
faut changer le regard sur les ports
j'ai envie de lui dire mais il faut
changer votre regard sur la pauvreté
c'est votre regard le problème
effectivement la pauvreté c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas une donnée nature
c'est un problème de société
si c'est quelque chose que la société
crest la pauvreté c'est pas quelque
chose de naturel qui est de l'ordre
naturel et qui est voué à exister pour
pour tous les temps donc oui bien sûr
qu'on peut agir sur la pauvreté bien sûr
mais pour ça faut vraiment changer de
modèle de société et manuellement
on n'est pas là dedans sur son plan
dernier point avant de laisser la parole
enfin avant de commencer à faire des
plans pauvreté j'ai des amis tout ce
qu'il dit c'est d'abord rend les 5 euros
d'apl et puis après on discute antoine
aumônier avant de rentrer dans le détail
car harnois a commencé mais avant de
rentrer dans le détail du plan annoncé
cette semaine quelques chiffres la
bourgogne franche comté en matière de
pauvreté est en quelque sorte un faut
toujours mettre des mais plutôt préservé
le taux de pauvreté c'est 13% ses 14 et
demi pour cent au niveau national et
puis le taux de chômage on l'oubli aussi
souvent parce que parfois on voit là la
franche-comté peut-être plus pauvres ou
moins bien qu'elle n'ait mais le taux de
chômage est plus faible en franche comté
que au niveau national alors ça
représente quand même plus de 2 de plus
de 350 mille personnes pauvres en
bourgogne franche comté des personnes
qui vivent avec moins de douze mille 100
euros par an c'est à dire autour de 1000
euros par mois ces personnes vivent tels
la pauvreté comme une fatalité et
ont-elles une chance de s'en sortir
moi j'ai bien aimé l'ouverture que vous
avez montré du changement de regard
parce que d'une part parce que c'est une
campagne confère depuis plusieurs années
lutter contre les préjugés sur le regard
de la société par rapport aux personnes
en situation de précarité
la situation des gens elle est elle et
elle est très différente des chiffres
statistiques voilà effectivement on peut
on peut avoir ces chiffres en tête et en
même temps chaque situation est
particulière et c'est pour ça que peut
être appréhendé ce plan de lutte contre
la pauvreté d'une manière globale est
pas simple parce que quand on commence à
parler de changement de regard
c'est aussi qu'on dit même là quelque
chose qui n'est pas monétaire qui et
comment la société comment chacun
d'entre nous regarde les personnes quand
elles sont très différentes de nous est
en difficulté alors justement ce fameux
plan pauvreté c'est son ambition
envisager la problématique de façon
globale on l'a vu dans l'extrait le sous
titre du plan c'est faire plus pour ceux
qui ont moins
est-ce que ce pari là ce slogan est ce
que ce pari est tenu cette promesse est
tenue
en tout cas on sent que le gouvernement
a beaucoup consulté
on a fait partie d'eux comme d'autres
associations des associations qui ont
été consultés pour partager cette
expérience de la précarité
bien sûr on aurait voulu plus sur
certains domaines et notamment cette
fameuse augmentation du rsa parce que
faire changer la pauvreté comme c'est
l'ambition du gouvernement du président
de la république sur une génération
ça prend du temps une génération c'est
long et en attendant il faut pouvoir
vivre et du coup le rsa qui est un peu
le socle peut aider des personnes à dans
la durée à revenir progressivement vers
l'emploi mais en tout cas l'orientation
et le fait qu'on décide un plan national
de lutte contre la pauvreté
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle alors dans
ce plan
il ya un accent mis clairement sur la
jeunesse l'accès facilité aux crèches
les petits déjeuners à l'école la
cantine à 1 euro pour les familles en
situation de précarité la scolarité
obligatoire dès 3 ans vous qui est
enseignante claire arnoux est ce que
c'est une bonne idée de prendre le
problème justement sur les plus jeunes
ben c'est une bonne idée de prendre le
problème déjà ça c'est sûr on va pas on
va pas critiquer ça donc c'est bien il
ya une partie des mesures qui sont qui
sont bonnes moi je suis pour la cantine
and rush même puisque pour ça parce que
ce qu'on propose nous c'est qu'on fasse
enfin des gratuite bio des cantines bio
gratuite ce qui est un volet
d'entraînement aussi sociale et de
création d'emplois si on revient sur les
cantines un euro mon truc c'est une très
bonne chose
maintenant les enfants ils sont pas hors
de leur famille c'est à dire que c'est
quand même un problème global bien sûr
qu'il faut prendre en compte les enfants
mais il faut aussi prendre en compte les
familles dans leur ensemble et si quand
il rentre à la maison c'est nouveau la
misère ça passe pas et effectivement
c'est pour ça que on a tout à fait
raison de reparler du rsa puisqu'à la
base il ya il ya tout simplement une
question concrète matériel de ce conte
de ce que les gens peuvent avoir chez
eux et de ce qu'ils peuvent acheter de
ce qu'ils peuvent avoir comme droit
aussi donc c'est quand même un
gouvernement qu un gouvernement
d'austérité qui réduit les droits
partout qui réduit les appels qui donne
pas de places en ehpad pour les
personnes les plus âgées c'est aussi la
pauvreté les personnes les plus âgées
comment ce gouvernement c'est vrai que
souligner comme un ya rien sur les aînés
maillard est pire que ça suffira les
ehpad
il supprime les budgets des ehpad c'est
à dire que moi je suis d'accord pour
mettre de l'argent sur les enfants
qu'après dernier point quand il a un
euro on n'a pas le détail du financement
est ce que ça va être aux collectivités
qui gèrent en plus sans fin qui gère
collectivement vous faites partie de
d'une majorité ici à besançon la cantine
à 1 euro l'accès universel aussi à la
cantine on a vu ça peut poser problème à
besançon puisqu'il ya eu une affaire
avec une maman qui aller en justice
comment finance ça ne serait ce que d'un
point de vue des bâtiments et de la
logistique
alors si vous me permettez pour juste
avant de répondre à votre question je
vais répondre sur un autre point puisque
à plusieurs fois on était j'ai entendu
parler avant on mettait deux répondent
aussi à ma caisse jean ou promet de
répondre à votre question juste après
mais plusieurs fois on
sur le sur la pl la diminution des 5
euros des apl c'est vrai mais je
voudrais aussi qu'on re mettre en
parallèle un certain nombre
d'augmentations vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure à peu près des gens qui touchait
1000 euros par mois il faut savoir qu'il
y en a qui touche beaucoup moins 1
l'adulte et le les adultes handicapés
vous savez que le gouvernement a décidé
d'augmenter de 100 euros quand même
l'aide c'est quelque chose de très
important sur le minimum vieillesse
le gouvernement a aussi décidé
d'augmenter de 100 euros ce montant là
c'est à dire sur les trois prochaines
années je crois que ce sont quand même
des éléments importants on n'a jamais vu
ça depuis 20 ans une augmentation aussi
importante sur ces minima sociaux là
quand on dit que le plan est pas
suffisant je peux le comprendre mais
c'est quand même un plan à lui milliards
sac qu'il est quand même très important
je rajouterais sur ce plan là parce
qu'il ya eu certaines critiques je
précise je réponds aux questions juste
après sur le logement parce qu'il ya un
autre un autre élément dans l'essai
aussi vote d'un manu présidente qui est
le logement d'abord et c'est quelque
chose en plus
il faudra qu'on en parle aussi aussi
pour répondre à votre question
concernant les cantines à 1 euro bien
entendu il y aura des aides de l'état
pour compenser ceux ci ya aussi et
l'accès universel à la cantine
comment on peut gérer ça au niveau d'une
commune il faudra gérer ça n'est déjà
pas le gérer actuellement vous avez pris
le cas donc des cantines à besançon où
on a fait des progrès puisqu'on à
l'année dernière on a retrouvé 80 places
on en a retrouvé encore 80 cette année
faut savoir qu'à besançon on a une
politique sur l'alimentation qui est
très intéressante on travaille sur des
produits bio en partie et puis en
liaison chaude donc bien entendu c'est
pas si simple que sable d'augmenter d'un
seul coup donc on a une réflexion
globale sur les cantines à besançon et
je voudrais dire sur les tarifs sociaux
pour pour les comment les cantines les
crèches et des choses très intéressantes
pour les quartiers prioritaires souvent
on dit que le président c'est le
président des riches
là ce sont dans les quartiers priori
plus haut si on n'oublie pas je crois la
ruralité
parce que actuellement sur les cantines
etc il n'y a pas de tarifs sociaux ou
peu dans les rues rallye dans la
ruralité et là on pourra les trouver une
question d'un téléspectateur emmanuel
qui nous dit faut-il faire de
l'assistanat à outrance ou bien
permettre aux personnes
difficulté de pouvoir vivre en toute
dignité en leur proposant un vrai
travail et un salaire raisonnable
antoine aumônier voulait répondre il ya
une partie insertion très importante
dans le discours du président de la
république
la piste de de quitter la pauvreté en
retrouvant un emploi elle est sans doute
la bonne orientation
parce que c'est c'est la grande
difficulté pour la plupart
l'expérimentation territoire zéro
chômeur à la fait ses preuves
c'est une bonne nouvelle qu'on puisse la
déployer la porte d'entrée dans l'emploi
allait souvent trop haute
effectivement faut par s'installer ce
convoi nous souvent année après année
c'est qu'il ya des personnes qui
s'installent qui sont installés dans la
pauvreté qui n'arrive plus à en sortir
et donc après n'arrive plus à trouver un
emploi parce que tous les problèmes se
sont multipliés
vous parlez de l'association territoires
zéro chômeur je précise
en fait c'est y partent du principe que
c'est un manque à gagner pour l'état que
y ait des personnes au chômage et ils
réinvestissent cet argent en manque à
gagner pour créer des emplois alors il
ya des ia 10-10 territoire test je crois
en france ait eu 600 emplois de créés il
y en a un en bourgogne
il n'y a même pas une collectivité en
franche comté qui se porte candidate
pour l'instant donc moi je veux bien que
ça marche mais c'est encore à un niveau
très faible
est-ce que là on met pas assez de on
valorise pas assez ce type d'expérience
on valorise pas assez ce type
d'expérience il ya quand même des choses
qui sont en maturation dans le jura ne
pas faire de ce couple aujourd'hui mais
il ya des choses qui qui viennent dans
cette direction et qui je pense dans le
courant de l'année peuvent en dessous
non plus s'il table se porter candidat
se porter candidat et cd expérience très
intéressante parce que du coup on fait
du sur mesure
voilà c'est plus l'emploi qui va
déterminer la candidature mais c'est le
profil de la personne qui crée l'emploi
le service public de l'insertion promis
par le président de la république vous
avec quel regard de ce gadget ou vraie
évolution 1
en tout cas si ça permet un
accompagnement comme ils disent renforcé
vers l'emploi que ça permet de mettre
localement dans les territoires tout le
monde autour de la table les
associations les professionnels les
collectivités locales pour trouver des
solutions
qu'ils soient efficaces à ce moment là
je pense qu'on s'adapte on s'adapte bien
la situation
la pauvreté parce que j'étais
multifactorielle et on peut jamais de
trouver une solution pour une situation
de pauvreté il faut qu'on soit nombreux
autour de la table je vous ai pas posé
la question sur la jeunesse vous les
initiatives qui ont été le petit
déjeuner l'accès favorisés aux crèches
les aides pour les nounous tout ça vous
vous trouvez ça bien ou bien sûr je peux
pas bien sur un an mais on est très très
heureux de ça la seule difficulté que
nous rencontrons c'est tout le volet
d'aidé des migrants et des gens et des
femmes immigrantes qui sont dans une
forme de clandestinité et je ne sais pas
si elles auront accès à tous ces
dispositifs demain je le souhaite
vraiment parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est tout
un volet de la précarité qui est peu
payant alors il ya une grande question
aussi par rapport à ce plan contre la
pauvreté c'est la création du fameux
revenu universel d'activité alors on va
pas de l'appeler les rues le président
de la république nous a bien fait
comprendre qu'il ne fallait pas
l'utiliser comme ça on parler comme ça
on va fusionner donc un grand nombre de
prestations sociales le rsa les apl avec
des droits et des devoirs
supplémentaires qu'elle de voir pascal
curie qu'est-ce qui va falloir faire
dorénavant pour toucher ses appels alors
déjà je pense que c'est bien de
travailler sur l'eau sans l'ensemble de
ces dispositifs y ait au moins 18
dispositif les jours sont perdus dans
les dispositifs quand ils ont besoin d
aide
il faut savoir que woods sur le rsa vous
avez 30 personnes trente pour cent des
gens qui ne demandent même pas le rsa
donc le c'est à peu près la même chose
sur l'ensemble des allocations ce que
c'est des milliards donc qu'il devrait
auquel les gens ont droit qu il ne
demande pas qu'il ne demande pas parce
que le même et ça remet en cause si vous
laissez ça c'est intéressant de le
préciser parce que c'est ça le ceux qui
disent que qui critique un assistanat et
en fait il ya énormément de pauvres qui
ont droit à des allocations et qui ne
les demande par les deux bandes pas
parce que le parcours est beaucoup trop
compliqué je vous dis 18 dispositif
c'est trop important
donc l'objectif c'est essayer de
réfléchir pour avoir essayé de
globaliser l'ensemble de ces dispositifs
alors ce qui est intéressant c'est que
c'est pareil le gouvernement a décidé de
travailler avec les associations
il se donne à peu près six mois
justement pour essayer de réfléchir sur
ce revenu là quelque chose à la question
quels devoirs pour toucher des appels
alors c'est le devoir c'est je pense pas
qu'il ya un devoir
alors monsieur l'a dit tout à l'heure et
je crois que c'est un élément très
important
c'est à dire qu on ne supprimera par la
pauvreté si on retrouve pas d'emploi
donc c'est quoi c'est faire partie du
dispositif soit décidé de retourner à
l'emploi si c'est possible vous savez il
ya des gens qui sont c'est très
compliqué on a parlé du rsa le rsa donc
il faut suivre les gens très rapidement
actuellement au lit suis pas assez
rapidement vous avez de type il ya des
gens qui peuvent retourner dans le monde
du travail assez rapidement donc ceci il
faut les ai dit tout de suite et y en a
d'autres qui sont plus éloignés du
travail il faut les aider il faut les
aider à faire des formations ou essayer
de travailler avec des temps partiels ou
des choses comme ça c'est des choses que
l'on fait un petit peu à besançon la
avec le ccas est une association au
travail avec le dispositif tapage qui
permet à des gens de venir travailler et
on les paye à la journée je crois que
c'est un élément important car nous
serons revenus unis
marcel d'activité c'est une catastrophe
j'entendais monsieur pascal curie qui
disait que le reste allait être
augmentée il allait être augmentée mais
assorti de tout un ensemble de
conditions et donc ils le font de ces de
ses droits
en fait les transforme en une obligation
il y a sorti des obligations et c'est
quand même assez catastrophique donc en
fait on voit aujourd'hui notamment c'est
déjà ce qui se pratique dans pôle emploi
ou faut accepter ce qu'ils appellent
deux offres raisonnables d'emploi sinon
on perd ses droits et là c'est ce qu'ils
veulent faire avec le rsa elle les
appelle donc c'est vraiment
catastrophique pour le coup c'est
vraiment une possibilité que hier encore
moins de personnes qui touchent le
revenu universel d'activité est encore
une fois là c'est le regard des manuels
mâcon qui pose problème puisque quand il
fait ça il pense qu'elle est une demande
des associations et de beaucoup de
professionnels qui gère ces dossiers là
de fusionner pourrait aimer thé dansant
mais au delà de la sortir d'obligations
pas de le sortir de l'obligation de
d'accepter ce qu'ils appellent une offre
raisonnable d'emploi et là c'est
catastrophique
et là on voit qu'il a un problème sur la
manière dont ils considèrent les
personnes parce que encore une fois
c'est la personne qui est elle même
responsable de sa situation qui doit
s'en sortir qui doit donc accepter des
offres raisonnables d'emploi penser que
même si tous les emplois étaient pourvus
il resterait pour une offre d'emploi il
ya quarante chômeurs donc même si toutes
ces personnes-là acceptent des offres
raisonnables d'emploi
il reste trente neuf personnes sur le
carreau donc on voit bien qu'il est
toujours dans cette même mentalité dans
cette même mentalité libéral
individualistes ou en fait c'est pas il
n'a pas changé de regard il est toujours
dans la même poursuit de ce qui se
faisait auparavant antoine aumônier
cette fusion des des prestations ça va
permettre de diminuer le non-recours son
appel le non recours aux prestations
alors on compense effectivement au
secours catholique que ça va l'aider
il ya déjà une expérimentation qui était
fait sur le chèque énergie cette année
qui a été faite un peu sur le même
principe on reçoit un chèque s'est
envoyé de manière automatique sur la
base de l'analyse des foyers fiscaux ce
qu'on espère c'est que ces fusions
effectivement qui sont un vrai une vraie
complexité pour les personnes en
précarité de faire toutes les démarches
de d'aller rencontrer des
administrations avec les quelques fois
avec lesquels quelquefois ils n'arrivent
pas à communiquer avec maintenant le
passage par le portail informatique
ça va simplifier les choses ça va sans
doute évité le non recours si ensuite on
franchit une étape qui pourrait être
l'automaticité aussi de l'accès à
l'enrayer l'instant à rien n'a été dit
mais il a été dit qu'il y aurait une
concertation un débat et que ce serait
pas forcément ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui sur la question de pôle
emploi et l'acceptation des deux offres
et on espère qu'il y aura un vrai
dialogue qui permettra d'ouvrir
justement à des critères qui soit une
contractualisation mais sur plusieurs
items et pas seulement sur un seul pour
vous on fait de l'assistanat à outrance
aujourd'hui en france
ah non je pense pas non je pense pas
qu'on fasse ça d'ailleurs ce que vous
venez de dire est le montre c'est qu'il
ya 30 % non recours nous les gens qu'on
voit passer on a 40% de personnes qui ne
recourent pas à leur aide
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ne recourent
pas à leur aide pas seulement à cause de
la question de la complexité mais aussi
à cause du regard qui est porté sur par
la société par eux mêmes quand ils vont
avoir accès à ces aides
et puis par quelques fois les
administrations vers lesquels ils vont
faire ces démarches et pour lesquels ils
n'ont pas le langage et ils sont pas
forcément bien bien accueilli donc je
pense qu'on n'est pas dans cette logique
là mais quand on met les gens en
situation de deux d'être partie prenante
d'être actif dans la manière dont ils
vont utiliser ces parcours et bénéficier
de ces aides
je pense que ça aide énormément chacun à
être voie la plus responsable mais c'est
aussi le regard de la société qui doit
changer
alors justement le regard à besançon je
vais vous donner la parole pascal curie
parce qu'on va parler notamment de cet
arrêté municipal interdisant la
mendicité dans certaines rues du centre
ville de besançon
ça a créé la polémique il ya eu des
manifestations
je vous propose d'ailleurs d'écouter
trois manifestants opposés à cet arrêté
pris par le maire cet été j'estime
qu'une espèce d'acharnement contre des
gens qui sont déjà excusé à la base
plutôt que de seuil et de prendre le
problème à sa source et de faire
autrement parce qu'on peut très bien
vivre tous ensemble c'est une sept jours
de rendre visible ce qui déplaît parce
que ça fait pas propre dans les villes
c'est des personnes qui sont déjà dans
le besoin qui n'ont pas grand chose pour
vivre et le peu qu'ils peuvent avoir
entre guillemets c'est un bout de
trottoir et on est en train de leur
retirer alors on est un petit peu dans
l'ère de la communication
quand il ya une nappe de pétrole en mer
on met du dispersant quand ya un camp de
migrants installés parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'autre solution
on le démantèle et puis quand y'a un peu
trop de sdf dans la rue ont fait un
arrêté mais en quoi est ce que ça résout
les problèmes parce qu'elle curie en
quoi cela résout les problèmes de
prendre un rite un arrêté interdisant la
mendicité dans certaines rues du
centre-ville de besançon
alors c'est un arrêté qui a fait
beaucoup parler alors vous l'appelez
arrêté anti mendicité c'est pas ça du
tout ça n'arrêtait contre les troubles
publics simplement
donc après il ya eu une interprète la
consommation d'alcool la mendicité
accompagnés ou non d'animaux les
regroupements la station assise ou
allongée sont interdites
c'est c'est bien la mendicité parmi une
liste de choses qui est interdit je
reprends c'est à dire c'était bien
l'objectif était bien donc un arrêté
contre les troubles publics
c'est ce qui avait été dit qu indique
etc il est vrai que sur l'arrêté il ya
une petite ambiguïté il faut savoir
quand même que le tribunal ne l'a pas
rejeter s'est arrêtée il ya une petite
ambiguïté c'est tout simplement pour ça
que le maire a décidé de légèrement
modifié l'arrêté
parce que il ne ciblait pas du tout la
mendicité l'objectif n'est absolument
pas ça donc je pense qu'on va pas parler
trop longtemps de ça c'était absolument
pas ça c'est un mec quand le président
de la république lui-même demande de
change elles regardent ça bellehigue
matiz un petit peu la main on comprenait
bien que c'était contre les troubles
publics et pas contre la mendicité il
fallait prendre un arrêté municipal pour
ça alors que dans sa compétence le maire
a de toute façon il peut intervenir pour
trouble à l'ordre public pas partout
quand vous
et personne allongée quelque part on n'a
pas forcément tous les tous les outils
il perturbe pas fonctionné forcément
mais s'ils sont allongés devant un
magasin c'est compliqué voilà antoine au
money vous a choqué cet arrêté municipal
ce qui ce qui m'a choqué c'est le fait
que enfin c'est ce que disait cette
personne sur l'interview vous avez
montré c'est face à un problème global
qui nécessite un plan national de lutte
contre la pauvreté il n'y a pas de
réponse simple et du coup on aurait
plutôt souhaité une concertation avec
les commerçants les gens question les
riverains les travailleurs sociaux
peut-être les associations et qu'on
cherche ensemble des solutions durables
à un problème qui va se répéter je pense
régulièrement chaque saison estivale
chaque saison où il y aura plus de
tourisme dans besançon
je pense que là à chaque fois qu'il ya
une question de fond comme celle là il
vaut mieux qu'on soit nombreux autour de
la table pour essayer de trouver les
bonnes solutions qui vont changer
quelque chose sur le regard qu'on porte
les uns sur les autres et quelquefois il
suffit de se parler dans un cadre qui
permette de s'entendre plutôt que de
prendre des décisions comme ça un peu
rapidement d'autant que ce que j'ai
compris c'est qu'il y avait pas eu
vraiment de débat municipal puisqu'il ya
un certain nombre de gens qui étaient là
qui ont voté et qui ont a priori il n'y
a pas eu de vote
un arrêté municipal ses compétences du
maire il a demandé si j'ai bien compris
lors d'une réunion où il y avait les
élus de la majorité leur avis mais ils
n'ont pas voté non mais pas une
discussion et de l'okano position claire
arnoux vous faisiez partie de ces
manifestants a fait partie on était
nombreux et il y avait il y avait des
gens de la france est soumise mais il ya
aussi plein d'associations et plein de
citoyens donc c'était vraiment un
collectif large et effectivement c'est
une vraie honte enfin je dirais c'était
marqué interdiction de la motricité donc
après on peut inventer tout ce qu'on
veut c'est est une population qui est
ciblé et dans le nouvel arrêté anti
mendicité enfin dans le nouvel arrêté
qui doit résoudre des troubles à l'ordre
public on retrouve toujours cette même
population stigmatisée dans les dents
les considérant donc en fait c'est
toujours la même population parle plus
de mendicité on parle de sollicitations
l'égard des passagers les arrêtés sous
les vous pouvez lire on dit aussi
considérant le nom l'augmentation du
nombre de personnes accompagnées ou non
de chiens au centre-ville mais qu'est ce
que ça veut dire quoi enfin à part
stigmatiser une population en
particulier qu'est ce que
ça veut dire maintenant je reviens sur
tout le plan macro parce que monsieur
pascal curie moi je suis désolé quand
vous défendez ça alors que vous êtes au
conseil municipal et que vous voyez
l'asphyxié des collectivités
territoriales ou sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat c'est 13 milliards qui va
être ôtés à l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales et que vous avez le culot
de nous dire que le plan pauvreté ça va
résoudre des choses alors que c'est
enfin je veux dire 8 milliards sur
quatre ans pour le plan pauvreté ces
cinq milliards par an pour les riches
avec les y est c'est fait la flat tax
donc un moment donné il ya juste quelque
chose aussi de cohérence à avoir et vous
en tant qu'élu comment vous pouvez
défendre ça alors que vous savez que le
budget du ccas n'a pas augmenté alors
que la pauvreté a augmenté à besançon
pascal curieux je vais répondre par
rapport donc aux dotations
il faut savoir que maintenant rentrer
dans un dispositif de contractualisation
avec l'état frais si vous voulez c'est
fini je peux vous dire qu'en cumulé sur
les dernières années la ville a eu des
diminutions de dgf de façon très
importante plus de 20 millions d'euros
avec le dispositif de contractualisation
que la ville a passé
simplement si on ne dépasse pas 1,2 pour
cent donc de nos dépenses
on aura pas de diminution ce qui veut
dire que c'est complètement faux ce que
vous dites c'est à dire qu'on sera
beaucoup moins pénalisé que les années
précédentes où on avait deux fils des
diminutions de la dgf là on aura si on
rend respecte le contrat que mouhssine
sur la ville de besançon
on aura pas de diminution merci à pascal
pour courir seulement c'est terminé on
sentit nu a parlé du plan pauvreté avec
francis letellier reçoit valérie rabault
présidente du groupe ps à l'assemblée ce
sera juste après votre flash
d'information bon dimanche à tous
[Musique]